[Música]
vamos con salud y con Mara Romero sala
para hablar de los temas más importantes
mar Buen día para usted Buen día Ángela
este año 2023 era la meta marcada de la
OMS para eliminar las grasas trans de la
dieta se ha cumplido el objetivo Bueno
creo que no nos sorprenderá decir que no
que nos habló no se ha cumplido sino que
estamos muy lejos Aunque es justo decir
que ha habido un cierto Progreso no este
objetivo Está marcado por la legislación
de los países que pasen leyes que
protejan o eliminen las grasas atrás de
los productos industriales y
alimenticios y a pesar de que ha
aumentado la cantidad de países que
cuentan con esta protección ahora no en
total se calcula que 2.800 millones de
personas viven en países protegidos por
esta legislación todavía la OMS Calcula
que hay 5.000 millones de personas en
países que no tienen ningún tipo de
protección contra este tipo de grasas en
los alimentos Aquí vemos el panorama en
América Latina en verde oscuro los
países que cuentan con digamos la
protección óptima considerada por la
Organización Mundial de la Salud pero
vemos que hay países por ejemplo como
Ecuador como Colombia que tienen unos
límites menos restrictivos o por ejemplo
países como México que simplemente
cuentan con la pues la política de
marcar en el empaquete en el embalaje
que esos alimentos contienen grasas
precisamente la Organización Mundial de
la Salud ayer hacía un llamado para
acelerar el proceso o sea estamos mal
estamos mal bueno Porque este tipo
en 2023 necesitamos acelerar el progreso
para lograr esta importante objetivo en
la salud global sería el primer factor
de riesgo en enfermedades no
transmisibles como las de corazón que se
eliminaría
me quedé en la mitad de la pregunta por
qué este tipo de grasas son tan
riesgosas para nuestra salud aquí el
meollo del asunto claro una pregunta
clave en realidad no se consideran que
son las las peores de todas existen
también en productos naturales por
ejemplo en la carne de vaca también en
los productos lácteos pero sobre todo la
mayor proporción de estas grasas está en
los productos industriales Por qué Pues
porque se usan muchos productos como por
ejemplo mantequilla o margarinas que son
aceites que se pasan a estado Sólido y
precisamente ese paso es el que hace que
sean especialmente nocivos para nuestra
salud están muchos alimentos procesados
por ejemplo todos los fritos o los
productos horneados que se encuentran en
los supermercados es barato alarga la
vida útil de muchos de estos productos y
entonces pues es por eso que está
ampliamente usado sin embargo la
Organización Mundial de la Salud
defiende que se pueden sustituir con los
aceites sin Pues en el estado líquido en
aceites vegetales líquidos que no cambia
el gusto de la comida que tampoco cambia
el coste Así que no es tan difícil dar
este paso y nos estaríamos ahorrando
muchísimos problemas de salud Porque Qué
pasa cuando tomamos estas grasas Pues
contribuyen a aumentar el colesterol que
llamamos malo y a disminuir el
colesterol que llamamos bueno
precisamente este colesterol malo es el
que conocemos porque se pega a las
paredes de las arterias las puede
obstruir y aumentar el riesgo de
enfermedades del corazón particularmente
20% en aumento de riesgo de enfermedades
25% en el riesgo de muerte por estas
enfermedades En total son a 5000 Perdón
500.000 las muertes prematuras anuales
por consumo de estas grasas trans pues
Mire es que es más barato comer las
grasas que no son tan saludables uno
debería consumir menos canola más oliva
más mantequilla menos margarina pero
bueno acá nos podemos quedar con esa
discusión saludable vamos a cambiar de
tema y pasar 19 con la posibilidad de
cambiar a la estrategia de vacunación
cuéntanos de qué se trata Sí esa de ayer
Estados Unidos la fda que su entidad
reguladora de este tipo Pues de los
medicamentos anunciaba que estaba
valorando pasara una vacunación anual
contra el 19 al estilo de la gripe eso
podría convertirse de hecho en dos
anuales para personas con personas con
factores de riesgo y desde Estados
Unidos ya llegaban algunos pues
valoraciones positivas de expertos y
médicos escuchémoslo
desgraciadamente la aceptación de la
vacuna ha sido baja en las mejores
circunstancias solo el 35% de la gente
mayor de 65 años ha aceptado los
refuerzos y un porcentaje mucho más bajo
en niños y adolescentes ha recibido el
refuerzo Así que es hora de un cambio de
estrategia porque lo que estamos
haciendo ahora no funciona muy bien
esta nueva estrategia podría incluso
parecerse a la vacunación contra la
gripa corriente no claro ahí hay muchos
factores en los que sí algunos en los
que no De hecho todavía falta ver si en
algún momento habrá una sub variantes
muy distintas a las que circulan
actualmente como las de o micrones o
dificultaría hacerlo así también una
falta de regularidad en las estaciones
no porque la gripe la tenemos muy
predecible ciclos de invierno verano la
que sabemos Pues cuando va a llegar el
peor momento pero la verdad es que hay
una estrategia y una infraestructura
internacional muy importante la estamos
viendo aquí detrás es un consorcio un
programa global contra la gripe que lo
que hacen es que pues son laboratorios
que cooperan internacionalmente de
muchísimos países también con la
Organización Mundial de la Salud que lo
que hacen es secuenciar todos los virus
de las variantes de la gripe que esté
circulando en ese momento para que todos
los laboratorios puedan tomar eso como
referencia y desarrollar cada año una
vacuna nueva distinta contra la gripe
una con pequeñas variaciones como vemos
que está empezando a suceder ahora
contra la del covid-19 entonces bueno
como decíamos son infraestructuras y
programas que ya existen para poder eso
modificar anualmente si no tenemos
ninguna sorpresa de una gran variante
como pasó económico que vayan cambiando
que se vayan actualizando las vacunas ir
vacunando anualmente podría ser una
nueva aproximación una nueva estrategia
que también haría como decía el médico
mucho menos confuso pues la estrategia
que está actualmente funcionando tres
años y todavía nos falta mucho por
aprender muchísimo y muchísimo por
cambiar gracias a usted gracias Ángela
muy bien